in Vienna the capital of Austria there
are massive Flack towers that were
constructed in World War II dotted
around the city three pairs of
anti-aircraft Flack Towers forming a
defensive triangle around the city with
2.5 M thick steel reinforced concrete
walls the towers were practically immune
to bombing and were equipped with
massive anti-aircraft guns scattered
around its roof and lower platforms
these towers were so strongly built that
attempts to destroy them after the war
failed miserably they were filled with
explosives which when detonated only
managed to crack the shell which now has
to be held together with steel cables
for the safety of the public and so they
remain standing today towering over
Vienna serving as a dark reminder of the
city's World War II history